so starting before infinity war came out
there was tons of speculation on which
Avengers are going to die and even
though Thanos succeeded in Avengers
infinity war collecting all of the
Infinity stones and wiping out half of
the universe with his snap I think we
all expected something a little
different than half of the Avengers
dying because of his nap I for one
definitely thought that Iron Man was
dead at the end when Thanos stabbed him
and I think a lot of the fans thought
that some of our heroes were gonna die
by the hands of Thanos in a way like
this but we got the snap and I think a
good majority of everybody out there
believes that all these heroes will be
brought back to life but that does not
change the fact that some of our heroes
will probably die or retire in Avengers
4 you have the whole thing with the
original Avengers where their contracts
are up and no one has renewed yet and
now the studio itself is even weighing
in saying there is going to be a
definite ending in Avengers 4 they have
said that the storylines over the past
10 years everything that's been built up
since the very first Ironman all these
stories are going to come to an end and
then a recent interview Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige had some things to
say about Avengers 4 and some of the
stories coming to an end in the
interview he talked about the impact
that Avengers 4 will have on the MCU and
that it's gonna have major ramifications
and it's also gonna serve as a
definitive ending to a story that
started with Ironman so major
ramifications and a definitive ending to
me means deaths or at least one death
while talking about these storylines
Kevin Feige said this but storylines can
come to an end the best stories do come
to an end Return of the Jedi wasn't
ending for a long time and as a
ten-year-old in 1983 that carried me
through 30 years until there was a
sequel that hasn't happened before in
the superhero genre a new actor comes in
and a new storyline starts right away we
wanted to do it this way because we
think that the best stories have a
definitive ending to a storyline that's
currently what's going to happen next
year with Avengers 4 so it seems like a
vendor's 4 is going to be like nothing
we've ever seen in the MC
or with any superhero cinematic
franchise for that matter we know that
they're bringing new characters in like
Captain Marvel and we know that they're
bringing other new characters in that
we've seen in the comics but we have
never seen in the MCU so there's
definitely going to be a shift after
Avengers for whether that is characters
dying characters retiring new characters
coming in or whatever it may be things
are going to change in the MCU after
Avengers 4 but the great news is that
everyone at Marvel Studios is super
excited for what's to come
after Avengers 4 and not to mention
there are a lot of characters from the
comics that could be introduced in the
MCU and if the Fox Disney deal goes
through who knows what we could see in
the MCU Marvel Studios has killed at
these past 10 years and I have no doubt
that the next 10 years will be the same
and I for one cannot wait to see the
x-man and the Avengers in the same movie
so what do you all think is going to
happen in Avengers 4 which characters do
you think will be leaving and which
characters do you think that they'll
bring into the MCU if you have any
thoughts or theories let me know in the
comments below
I'd love to talk about them hit the like
button before you leave and be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on Avengers 4 Marvel DC and
everything superhero thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you